la impaciencia se transforma en
desesperación a las afueras del
aeropuerto de los cayos la zona más
golpeada por el terremoto del sábado la
lenta llegada de la ayuda humanitaria
convierte las necesidades en
inaplazables no tenemos presidente no
tenemos congresistas no tenemos
senadores nos han abandonado estamos
solo a la espera de dios en la misma
zona en el suroeste del país las morgues
registran cifras de cadáveres sin
precedentes
el terremoto de 2010 no afectó tanto al
sur como esta vez la morgue registramos
algunas muertes pero no tan raras
muertes entre las ruinas a las que se
suman las causadas por el colapso
hospitalario ante la escasez de recursos
médicos las autoridades haitianas
listaron las necesidades concretas para
hacer frente a la urgencia
las necesidades sanitarias urgentes que
fueron identificadas por el ministerio
haitiano de salud incluyen la
movilización de personal médico general
y especializado a las zonas afectadas y
obtener medicamentos y suministros
médicos tales como antisépticos prótesis
ortopédicas entre otros también
necesitan apoyo logístico para la
entrega y el transporte de los pacientes
el actual primer ministro de haití y
prometió una mejor gestión de la ayuda
internacional para no repetir la
cronificación de la tragedia como en
lee luego que son de fondo
[Música]
los días que vendrán serán difíciles y
seguramente tristes invito a todos los
ciudadanos a seguir informándose
quiero recordar 519 sigue presente
woods y dwight hemos perdido demasiados
ciudadanos a causa de catástrofes
naturales debemos evitar perder más por
culpa de la pandemia
los fenómenos naturales agravan la
crisis sanitaria a la que se suma la
política tras el asesinato del
presidente joven el mois quedan en el
aire las elecciones previstas para
noviembre